Oh, my God.
What’s up dude?
What’s happening?
I'm here to caddie for ya today.
You look great.
Thanks, Bud.
you look pretty good Right now too.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, my God. That is...
No, no, that's nice.
Stop.
Ohhhh.
300.
that’s fairway, yeah?
Oh, yeah. Right there.
300.5.
Oh, boy.
That's pounded.
that close?
Got to be in the fairway, though.
Oh, no!
That would have had it, though.
Okay.
I think that's it.
It's leaking.
Go.
Ooo, it’s short.
That’s coming in high.
Lots of pressure here.
What is your handicap?
I'm, uh.
I think a 1.7 right now.
Love it. Love to hear that.
So you're playing a lot.
I love golf.
That's all I spend money on.
That's all I think about it.
Other than hockey.
That's a beautiful swing.
Go, Go.
All right.
What was the furthest?
300.
MATTHEWS.
I think we got it here.
Go, Go.
That takes you to about third place.
Pretty respectable, no?
What's the longest drive you've ever hit?
Longest drive?
Big guy.
Yeah, I can.
If I. If I.
It’s not Every time, by the way
that it is going too far,
but I think it's close to three hundo.
Nice.
All right, so now
we're going to put it to the test.
Just remember too
This is a longest drive.
Thanks.
Did we end up getting insurance or no?
Oh, I think
we're going to like this team.
No.
What do you mean? Yeah. Go.
No, I mean, it's in a great spot, but...
Dang.
I got to hit that harder.
Who drives it further?
You or Brady?
Brady.
He hits moonshots.
or big walt? [keith tkachuk]
Walter just likes to bunt it out there.
Short game guy.
think it opens up over there?
Hopefully no one's in the backyard.
Oh, yeah. Skate.
It's got to go.
at least we’re dancing.
You can live with that.
Yeah.
Oh.
Oh, no
are you sure this thing’s Right?
Cut that one out, please.
Oh, yeah.
That was hit good.
That was nuked.
I think that's got it.
No, Go, go.
Shh.
That's right down the pipe.
That's impressive.
I like that one.
I love that one.
Stay there.
I don't love it.
This is hard.
I'll take that drive, though.
I mean, that's. That's great.
Get to the green in two.
Yeah, no problem.
Dream celebrity foursome.
Have to think Tiger’s an obvious.
that's an obvious one.
Let's get Shaggy in there.
Nice!
That hot shot album.
one of the best ones out.
of all time, yeah.
It wasn't me.
Yeah, it wasn't.
Yeah, it wasn't him.
Let's round it out with someone like...
I feel like it'd be fun
to play with Peyton Manning.
Yeah.
You know?
I feel like you don't even need a fourth if you get Shaggy.
Yeah, I think he's the -
It's a twosome.
yeah, just you and shaggy.
I’ll caddy. done.
skate.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, yeah. that's good I think.
Go, go.
All right.
This is pumped.
Stay in the Fair-
Oh, yeah, That's got It.
Go!
Yes, sir.
Winner, baby!
That's pounded.
No, no, I took a little off that one.
Oh yeah.
I still think it's left, though.
That one’s counting.
Oh, yeah.
Go.
Get going.
All right, we've got one in play.
270.
What do you think you usually hit when you're out on the course?
Uh, I'd probably
say somewhere around, like,
280 / 290
So We’ll give him 290.
If you could describe your swing in an emoji,
what would the emoji be?
Power
Is that an emoji?
The mind blow one.
Oh, nice.
Could be the one.
Stay there. Stay there.
kick left.
Oh yeah, that’s way past - Stop!
Hey now.
Hey, Now.
Boom.
318. Ladies and gents.
it Kels.
Yeah.
He's got nothing.